1st.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> NOW TO ANOTHER DATE, THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE LAST U.S.
TROOPS FROM AFGHANISTAN STARTED
OVER THE WEEKEND.
AS IT BEGAN, THE TOP GENERAL
SAID AFGHAN FORCES IN A
WORST-CASE SCENARIO COULD FACE
WHAT HE CALLED, QUOTE, BAD
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES AGAINST THE
TALIBAN WITHOUT U.S. ASSISTANCE.
CHARLIE D'AGATA IS IN
AFGHANISTAN FOR US WHERE HE
TALKED WITH A FEMALE MAYOR WHO
FEARS A TALIBAN TAKEOVER.
>> Reporter: ZARIFA KNOWS FULL
WELL THE REACH OF THE TALIBAN
EVEN WITH AMERICAN TROOPS HERE.
YOU'VE HAD SEVERAL ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPTS ON YOUR OWN LIFE.
>> YEAH.
THREE TIMES.
>> Reporter: AT 27, THE YOUNGEST
MAYOR IN AFGHANISTAN, ONE OF THE
ONLY WOMEN TO HOLD THE POSITION,
LITTLE WONDER THE TALIBAN WANTED
HER DEAD.
SHE'S FLOWN TO D.C. TO IT
RECEIVE THE INTERNATIONAL WOMEN
OF COURAGE AWARD.
>> I CAME BACK, AND I STOOD MY
GROUND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Reporter: AND BACK HOME, A
DEATH SENTENCE FROM THE TALIBAN.
[ CHANTS ]
SHE PULLED OVER AT A PHARMACY
FOR HAND SANITIZER WHEN GUNMEN
OPENED FIRE ON HER CAR.
>> AND THEY STARTED SHOOTING MY
CAR FROM THIS WAY, THIS WAY,
THIS WAY, THIS WAY, AND THEN
FROM IN FRONT.
SHOOT, SHOOT, SHOOT, SHOOT.
>> Reporter: TWO MORE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS FOLLOWED.
>> JUST DAYS LATER THEY MURDERED
MY DAD.
I NEVER KISSED HIM -- I NEVER --
IT WAS SO HARD.
>> Reporter: WOMEN ESPECIALLY
FEAR THE TALIBAN WILL RETAKE
POWER AND REVERSE THE GAINS OF
THE PAST TWO DECADES.
UNDER THE TALIBAN, THEY WERE
IMPRISONED INSIDE THEIR OWN
HOMES, FORCED TO WEAR THE BURQA
OUTSIDE IT.
DR. NAFASHOU RECALLS BEING
SUFFOCATED.
>> WE COULDN'T SEE OUR WAY, HOW
TO WALK.
AND I MYSELF, I COULDN'T BREATHE
EVEN.
>> Reporter: DR. SHAFAVHAN FEARS
THE TALIBAN RETURN IS
INEVITABLE.
>> I HAVE THREE DAUGHTERS.
MY DAUGHTERS ARE STUDYING WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO THEIR LIVES.
>> Reporter: SHE SAYS EVEN IF
THAT HAPPENS, SHE'LL KEEP
FIGHTING FOR HER COUNTRY AND HER
FREEDOM.
IF SOMEBODY ASSASSINATED MY
FATHER, I'M NOT SURE I WOULD
CONTINUE YOUR JOB.
>> BUT I DO.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT WAS NOT GOD GIFT ED, CITIES
BUILD IT THEMSELVES.
>> Reporter: AS THE UNITED
STATES DRAWS DOWN, THAT FIGHT
FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS IS ONLY GOING
TO GET HARDER.
IN TALIBAN-HELD AREAS, THEY'VE
ALREADY STOPPED GIRLS FROM GOING
TO SCHOOL.
ANTHONY?
>> CHARLIE D'AGATA WITH SOME
MORE POWERFUL REPORTING FROM
KABUL.
THANK YOU.
>> I WAS WONDERING THAT EXACT
QUESTION THAT CHARLIE ASKED HER.
AND THE WAY SHE LOOKED AT HIM
AND SAID "I DO."
>> YEAH.
THAT'S RESOLVE FOR YOU.
>> I REALLY ADMIRE HER
DETERMINATION AND HER
FEARLESSNESS REALLY.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE FEARLESS.
>> Y